In this section, we're going to continue with our hands-on animating an engine, jumping
right back into Unreal Engine and walking through using the animation assembly we just
created in the last section to apply the inverse solve.
As we work through the inverse solve exercise to apply the animation assembly to our control
rig, you can once again choose to follow along or skip ahead to when you see the video jump
back into the slide deck.
There, we will review the steps used applying the inverse solve to the control rig in Sequencer.
Now let's get to it.
Where we left off with our animation assembly is the example that is completed and ready to go.
Now, I want to work non-destructively, so I'm going to start with the animation assembly
example that we just created and I'm going to duplicate it.
And in this case, I'm going to call this inverse solve, is, ex for example.
And the reason I keep this short is because I'm going to be adding to this as I go through.
Now I've saved it again and I'm going to drag this over to the inverse solve folder.
And the reason I'm going to move over to that folder is because here I have some examples.
Now, if you move things around, you do want to make sure that once you're done, you right-click,
go up to the fixed redirectors and hit fixed redirectors to make sure that there are no
problems with any of the pathing of your files.
Now, I have my IS example.
You can see that I'm still in my assembly example, but I want to open up my inverse
solve example.
I'm in my inverse solve example.
And from here, I again want to work non-destructively.
But I want to start by adding in and working through the inverse solve.
This is going to bake this animation track onto the control rig.
To do that, I just right-click on the animation for the mannequin and I go right up into the
control rig section and I choose mannequin control rig.
That's going to bring up a menu and that menu is going to give me some options.
I'm going to ignore most of these options right now, especially the export.
And I could do some reduce keys, but I want to keep everything just to show you that everything
gets added and baked onto this.
So I'm going to hit create and it's going to bake pretty quickly.
So from there, the animation track gets muted.
And the mannequin control rig now contains every animated key for every control that
is applied to the entire control rig.
It also moves me into animation mode.
So you can see I have my anim outliner, my anim details panel, and my animation ready.
And my control rig is on my character.
Now, I'm going to go ahead and save this because again, I want to work non-destructively.
And from here, I'm going to go ahead and duplicate this again.
And I'm going to call this isanim example.
And the reason for that is that I want to work on the animation at this point.
And the first thing that I want to do for working on my animation is move up to my control
rig, choose the plus button, and choose one of the two tracks that I'm going to use for
transforms.
Now, we're just going to modify this animation.
To modify the animation, I'm going to choose additive.
Now if I chose the absolute option, the absolute option would have overridden the key frames
that are on here.
From here, I'm working with my animation example, and I'm ready to start modifying my animation.
And I don't need the animation track anymore.
So I can select this track and delete it.
Now, my animation is driven by my control rig.
So you can see that as I move, my controls are moving.
Now from here, I can just go through my animation, find some adjustments, and select any control
and see where I want to fix things.
So if I look at my feet and I see where my feet move or slide, like this move down here,
you can see what twists and turns happen.
I can go ahead and make adjustments so that things match a little bit.
I can fix elbows, I can fix shoulder controls, you can see where any of this stuff is in
here.
And all I need to do to make these changes is just go ahead and grab some controls and
move them on out.
So let's move through the timeline and see where we start to get some pass through.
So a good rule of thumb is that as this pass through starts to hit here, I'm going to go
ahead and keyframe.
Just press S to keyframe.
And as that moves into place, I'm going to keep another S in here.
And you can see that's where that shift starts to take place.
I'm just going to keep keyframing as I'm ready to make some moves.
Grab a control and just push that on out, maybe raise this up a little bit so that the
arm moves a little bit back.
Maybe go ahead and rotate just a little bit so I get some other motion.
Push it back a little, enter a different pose.
And as you can see, I've got a pose that now blends in here out of the way.
Now I can go ahead and do this for some of the other controls.
Let's move to the other side.
You can see that it's passing onto the inside of this body.
I'm going to go ahead and fix that.
So where does that happen?
Right around here.
Let's start with a keyframe.
Let's move that hand so it rotates a little bit more.
And let's keyframe that out so that it's not passing into it.
So let's go ahead and key that pose.
Move over here.
And this is where we want to move it out.
And let's raise it up so it's not fully extended.
Because I don't want any hyperextension on my elbow.
And maybe twist that out so it moves a little bit further out.
Just hit S to make sure that my keyframe moves.
And let's also add in a little bit right over here so this kind of flows a little bit back
out.
Flop that arm a little bit more.
And let's move that back a little bit right over here.
Just to kind of get back into the original position.
Now I can blend in here.
And one thing you'll note is that as I build in my animations, I do have an option that's
in here that's not checked on automatically.
And that option is the weight.
So if I move into this section, you can see if I right click on the additive, I have a
weight option.
That weight option can be keyframed on and off.
Now as I move through, you can see I have the weight here.
I can blend this so that if I only add in certain animations and I scroll down to the
bottom of the transform, I can adjust the weight of those motions.
So you can see the good example here was that arm.
If I move between the weight on this control, I can adjust that weight just a little bit.
Now the value is 0 to 1.
So you can see that's where we were.
This is where we go.
And I can overdrive this to push it further.
Now I wouldn't necessarily want to do this.
I'm just going to go ahead and leave this as one.
But you can see that that option is there.
Now as you go through and you animate, you are going to run into the issue where you
want to be able to isolate what you're working on.
So to isolate, you just select the controls you want, make sure that you're still in sequencer,
and go ahead and hit the F10 key.
Now that will isolate the control that you're working on and show you what you've got for access.
Simply return to that to see all of your controls by hitting F10 again.
Now if you're hovering over a viewport and you hit F10, like in here where you're working,
and you hit F10, it's going to hide everything and you might get a little confused as to
what just happened.
If you look on your sides, left and right, you can see that all my tabs got hidden and
docked to the sides.
Now I just want to return to that, go ahead and hit F10 again and it restores your view.
Now as you work through your animation, feel free to polish that animation as much as you want.
Once you're done with your animation and you're happy with it, you can repeat this step and
then duplicate this again.
By duplicating this again, you can change this animation to AnimTrack, for example,
rather than being the inverse solve because this is going to be a baked track.
Now you can keep the inverse solve so you know which version or which iteration this is,
but again you're working non-destructively.
So from here you just go ahead and save this, then right click on the mannequin again and
now you want to bake an animation sequence.
Baking the animation sequence is going to give you a new animation path that's in here
and go ahead and name this to whatever the track you want to work with.
So in this example I'm going to call this ISNMTrack01.
So I want to keep this with my animation clips.
I'm going to make sure that I'm in the correct path.
For that I'm going to go into my courses folder.
I'm going to go into my 20501 section under my course topics.
I'm going to make sure that I'm in my hands-on section under my animation assembly and since
we're actually working with the inverse solve, I'm going to put it in my inverse solve folder.
I'll create a new folder for animation revisions and I'll go ahead and load that in here.
This way it's separated from my clips even though it's going to be a new clip.
Once I hit OK, I have similar options.
I have export options that are in here and I have a few to choose from.
Now I could make some modifications in here.
I could evaluate this in world space.
I could record this.
I can adjust quite a few different options that are in here, but I'm going to just use
the basic defaults for now.
Export that's going to create my track and you can see right here this is my animation
track.
Once that's done, I can apply this to the character and repeat the steps that I've already
done to polish my animation further and further and over and over.
Alright, let's jump back into our slides.
Alright, let's review everything we've just done inside Sequencer to apply the inverse
solve and modify the animation assembly.
And we started with step one, which was baking to Control Rig.
This is basically the inverse solve.
And to do this, we right-clicked on the SK Mannequin and brought up the options under
the Control Rig section.
There we selected the baked to Control Rig and chose the Mannequin Control Rig option.
This brought up a pop-up menu, which provides us options for baking and we chose the default
options for baking and hit Create.
This baked the animation assembly onto an SK Mannequin Control Rig that we are now going
to use.
After that, we duplicated the level sequence and added the Additive Transform track.
To do that, we hit the plus button on the Mannequin Control Rig, which contained all
of our keyframes and base animation that we didn't necessarily want to modify.
Using the Additive option in a duplicate level sequence allowed us to work non-destructively
to modify those animations and clean them up inside the Transform track.
The third step was just to animate with Control Rig to begin polishing, modifying our animation
in order to make it look better or to fix any overpulls or adjustments or anything that
didn't look right on our baked animation.
We also isolated select Control Rig controls using the F10 hotkey to focus on just the
controls that we wanted to work with inside Sequencer.
The end result is a slightly more polished version of our animation and from there we
could bake down the animation into a new level sequence.
That level sequence can then be applied back to the Mannequin and round tripped over and
over again to continuously polish our animation.
That's it for this section of our hands-on animating in-engine.
I hope you had fun applying the inverse solve and modifying your animation assembly.
Once again, I want to emphasize that this workflow can be used non-destructively and
repeated in order to polish and improve your in-engine animations.
In our next section, we will start to wrap up the Sequencer Animation Production Workflows
course with some final recommendations.